hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to custom night sister
location whatever you want to call it
we're back here again and we've got
dolls attack on the horizons which means
that we got the mini arenas that are
gonna try to drain our oxygen
we got bonnet trying to dance her way
across the screen who am I to stop her
but we also got the Biddy Babs and the
electro bass so the MIDI Bob is always
in the vent ahead when she gets too
close closed the vent until she retreats
electro babble appear randomly in east
or west and begin draining your power oh
no oh no okay for this one I actually
have to spend a good amount of time on
the cameras because I got to check the
middle then to see where Biddy Babb is
and I gotta check the side closets to
see where electro Babb is and then I got
a check on the mini Riina's that are
trying to drain my oxygen not a good
time all around but we're gonna try it
let's do this who knows maybe I'll win
on a first try will one shot this [ __ ]
and I will eat a muffin okay so we're
gonna need to add a lot in the camera
did you say don't hold it against us
Olo hey hey welcome to the party that's
not good okay hi well all right then you
know what I didn't actually need this
I'm just gonna go in blind
[ __ ] you oh geez oh there you are that's
no good
so that's done and out of there oh my
god
holy [ __ ] stop laughing at me
oh god they're draining my power oh boy
oh boy oh boy no you're not not at all
ah so there is definitely oh can you
imagine doing all of that with all of
the [ __ ] I just did with every of the
other one oh there's gonna be a [ __ ]
but I'm up to the challenge I can do
this it was getting easier as I was
going along trying to find the clues if
there were any audio clues stuff like
that I'm pretty sure I can do this so
let's get into it yeah bring it on
[ __ ] okay so I just got to be better
about flipping to the right spots on the
camera and hitting me a shock but
no you're not oh yes you are
oh that's yeah that's the auditory clue
that I need to listen for shut up that
was just that was just moving that was
the actual sound of that stop draining
my power that's like an absolute
priority so I can wait here and just
listen to the lovely sounds of them
laughing at me and then only go when I
need to stop them from draining my power
and also keep it general level head
wherever the hell that is
yeah I know it's hilarious I'm so
handsome it's ridiculous tension stop
Jesus
this is absolutely insanity but it's not
unmanageable the only problem is like
you drain a lot of power like and unless
I can get more power out of this next
half of this one I'm not gonna make it
because if it doesn't hit you're not if
it doesn't hit three am at fifty I'm
kind of [ __ ] I think I'm getting I
think I'm fine-tuning it like I am
getting closer to actually getting it
and it's it's a bit of a [ __ ] but it is
manageable once you actually get into
rhythm
yeah even if they're blocking your view
you don't really need to see because you
can get away with a whole lot more if
you're just very careful about what
you're doing and very quick with the
buttons yeah I'm not gonna make it on
this one I do it's like no way I'm gonna
make it on this one party why did you
come here okay but I can do that
it got yeah I got in a better rhythm I
can I can definitely do that [ __ ] but
that was insane not really it was
manageable it seemed insane because
there was a lot of moving parts but in
reality once you got used to it it was a
lot lot better so I can definitely do
that doing good I'm getting in a really
good rhythm about hitting my targets and
getting out of the key and getting out
of the camera screen effectively quickly
and effectively and just double-checking
where I need to in order to keep on top
of things
and as soon as I hear that freaking ding
dong enough the [ __ ] [ __ ] not also
known as building or wet then I'm good
goal if I were to stack the oxygen with
the power because then like I can
survive a little bit away from the
oxygen
but if I were to stack them then I don't
have to flip my camera up twice and
waste twice as much because I can deal
with low oxygen I just I shouldn't deal
like there did I get them I don't know
if I got him I and also it seems like
there may be some way to overlap one to
the other
I don't know I have no idea close real
quick also if you stack them they kind
of go off at the same time so that means
that you're always gonna be a bit more
predictable on the timer and that's
gonna be better for you locking locking
oh man it's getting crazy here at the
end here I think I'm gonna make it I
think I'm gonna make it good there roll
and roll and roll in roll and [ __ ]
roll in holy [ __ ]
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta got
it I got this is markiplier sealed off
for improvements
pardon the construction alright anyway
ok what's gonna happen now too bad don't
look at my skin it's not so sad why are
you so mad I'm not a good lad buy me not
the best lad why are you so bad I'm
not bad it's Adlon tad bit greenish
around the gills but that's not go bad
rattle rhymes let me go back to my pad
okay anyways shitty so we got that but I
think I'm gonna try one more here cuz
that took a little while okay girls
night that's not so bad I just got to
focus on Laura check on foxy
and then I don't have to deal with the
electro Babs cuz there are a son of a
[ __ ] MIDI Bab yeah this isn't so bad a
ball at all I just got to check on foxy
and do it kind of blind but that's okay
because I didn't need to hear anything
anyway so literally the only thing that
I need to flip up will be for foxy and
then listen to be Laura so this will be
a good exercise I'm kind of adding a lot
of rogue elements in here and also
making sure that my concentration is up
to maximum so I just need to be focusing
on foxy and listening to be Laura on
occasion but that shouldn't be so bad
and also remembering all the hotkeys
hello now also the oxygen I need the
oxygen oh there she is that majestic
creature I'll [ __ ] I completely forgot I
was supposed to be checking on foxy
that was definitely maybe oh that's it
that's it that's it right there
good oh god oh god that was close
oh lordy Lu okay all right this is a bit
hectic but not so bad that it's
impossible
definitely not impossible definitely not
impossible just gotta pay attention to
everything you got it okay I'm starting
to get it
I'm starting to get a feel for
everything independently it's like
having a lot of limbs whoa geez that's
not lethal yet not lethal sound yet oh
that is lethal down lethal oh god no oh
Jesus
Oh golly gosh well girls gasp it's a bit
of yes so I gotta tune it in to when the
exact moment of badness is
well that's that's the moment of madness
I shouldn't be yelling oh boy that
shouldn't be yelling as Yelling's Brad
okay we're good but not good on power
but good on trying and good on focus and
good on understanding exactly where I
need to go is when Foxy's gonna bang on
that foxy sorry you can't come in I mean
that's not a lot of patience to you know
you know you know knock on the door and
now not wait for me to respond so far
but Laura's been very nice
like very nice and as I say that she's
gonna suddenly not be nice that's nice
that's pretty good that's okay you know
that's all right you're all right okay I
was gonna win that one anyway okay
that's a bit I'm gonna keep trying this
one but I'm not gonna end it now I'm
gonna keep going cuz I want to make sure
that I can actually beat this alright
now that I got my hair out of my
freaking face maybe I'll actually be
able to do something right here who
knows probably not okay okay this is
okay now that I've gotten in a rhythm of
this this is literally not that bad
Laura is definitely manageable and less
of a threat than you think so long as
your understanding of exactly when she's
actually a threat which is not all the
time
I got this there's foxy [ __ ] that was
probably the most chaotic moment of the
whole entire round here house another
one she's moving over to the other side
good good good good
am I on target I don't think I quite am
maybe well I got a bit faster about that
particular transition yes I'm right on
target that's good that's really good
that's really good it's really good I'm
I'm gonna readily assume that I do lose
power to perfectly that literally
couldn't have gone better she's moving
yeah yeah that went really well that was
a smooth transition
let's move the staff ever had 5:00 a.m.
got it though I might just barely make
it might just barely make it
she's barely making it but not if Valora
is gonna hang out right there
good move move move okay okay we can do
this it's just a little more come on
stretch it okay the only problem being I
barely survived that with just them how
am I gonna survive with oh my god that's
bad oh my god my eyeballs poking through
my head oh man you know I think the
happy song time is over cuz Wow that is
horrifying
yeah no one's fooled by that yeah yeah
that guy's dead guys 100% dead he's dead
he's a walking corpse is a corpse walked
round
oh okay so the problem being we have now
experienced every single one of these
bastards and it's tough it is it is
rootin tootin tough it is man that is
tough these are not gonna be that hard
bottom shelf not gonna be the hard top
shelf not that hard it's just the fact
that golden freddy is literally
everybody at maximum so what does that
even mean like is there even remotely
enough power to do that is that a
feasible challenge I will find out
because I am going to keep continually
trying and I'll judge it based on how
far I get on whether or not I can
continue on I'll probably be tweeting
out live updates of my progress in this
whole [ __ ] experience but I will do this
because there has not been a single
other five nights at Freddy's game that
I have not completed the 20-20-20 mode
no matter how long it took and the
record currently I think is nine hours
for five nights at Freddy's 2 which was
just an obscene son of a [ __ ] with a
lot of elements but this one has just as
many so it's just about coordinating and
finding the exact rhythms and listening
when that is necessary so I will get to
that very soon I think I got I'm not try
to get through this this this and this
all in the next episode and then save
one more for golden freddy mode 20 20 20
20 point away 20 point 20 so thank you
everybody so much for watching look
forward to that very soon let me know
what you thought of this down in the
comments below let me know what you
think of my chances are whenever I get
to that point but thanks again
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]